i've noticed in my opinion i feel like
you straw man a lot of atheist arguments
so i understand the dictionary
definition of atheism is just somebody
there is no value right um but i think
it's a little bit deeper than that if we
want to talk about agnosticism and say
maybe god exists maybe it doesn't but i
don't have evidence of it so i don't
believe to my central argument whether
you're an agnostic or an atheist the
bottom line is that without the belief
that there is a purpose to the universe
without a belief that there is a purpose
to your life without a belief that you
have the capacity to make individual
choices it's very difficult to build a
civilization by difficult i mean
impossible